Like I've often thought of rep
of marriage as a wrestling match,
right?
If you're lucky,
the person that you marry
is someone you contend with.
It's not exactly,
I don't think it's exactly,
it's not tranquil.
Precisely.
You know,
you might have noticed
that some of you and,
but,
but the thing is if you have
something to contend against,
then that strengthens you and,
and that's actually better than
having nothing to contend against.
And so Jacob is the person who's also
strengthened by the necessity of this
contending and that that seems to be
the proper relationship with God or the
angel is that contending the battling,
right.
Rather than some sort of kind of loose,
weak statement of belief.
I mean,
I'm not trying to denigrate
that to any great degree.
It just doesn't seem like the
right motive conceptualization,
right?
Because human beings aren't,
aren't like that were
contentious creatures.
And that's actually seems to be something
that meets with God's favor in this
situation.
So especially given that that's actually
what he names the while the whole
kingdom of the chosen people is the idea
is that that's composed of those who
contend with God.
So that's,
that's a hell of an idea
that that's for sure.